okay I should be live I'm outside and in
California it's like 80 80 degrees right
now it's really nice weather and I'm
playing the super blitz hourly arena
which starts in about ten seconds and
this is gonna be a quick stream I don't
know if I'm going to finish the
tournament because I have dinner plans
with family wait a minute
oh the tournament was ending oh so the
next tournament starts in like four
minutes I wasn't paying attention
interesting let's go to the tournament
page yeah next tournament starts in
three minutes
hello to hero first one in the jacks
good to see you yeah so I have three
minutes to kill maybe I can do some
tactics let me join the tournament first
and then the game will start without me
forgetting to join and yeah let's do
let's try and do one puzzle kill some
time here I just took a very long hike
actually not too long but it felt long
it was like two hours it's like a mile
up a hill and then a mile down the hill
hello - I took five minutes on my name
very difficult name to pronounce
speaking of difficult actually I don't
think this problem is too difficult is
it just Bishop take out four is it that
easy this should take out four we skewer
it's the material situation I mean okay
these rooks are both attacked this
should take out four looks rushing
[Music]
guess it's equal material currently but
it's gotta be that [ __ ] take a floor
Oh a night Tiki eight threatening night
in my left six so now like this should
take t29 f6 King g7 I take you for a
rook take C 1 what sort of a trade
Bishop takes you one well we could also
just take on b8 immediately tricky
position
oh thanks for hosting me I took five
minutes on my name I'm hosting Lila
chest zero matches on me chest I don't
even know what that means if you can
explain that to me that would be nice
okay so there's a decision rook to e8
are you bishop take t2 I mean both moves
look better I should take T - no let's
let's take on Yeats it's gotta be now
then we take on d2 and repetition yay
just in time for the tournament okay
that was good timing I don't like
playing the moves in the like the puzzle
trainer until them like I'm absolutely
sure but okay climb to starts gonna play
d4 do I want to play another London
getting bored of London actually I'm not
really getting bored of London but I
feel like my viewers might be getting
bored of London let's play a different
type of opening and what I usually play
let's try and play it somewhat quickly
um some sort of like cattle and Sava
I think Knight d2 is a move or Queen c2
let's play 90 - hello - I'm singer 24
things are good
hello esta Chen hello mo - man
double-oh-seven
good to see you guys Carolus 25 have I
heard of alpha zero
I don't know there's too many chess
players out there who haven't heard it
alpha zero so I guess is Lee hs0
a kind of a a relative of alpha zero I'm
gonna play E for here looks normal and
then we're gonna are gonna trade ya
bucks going for more trades but White
has more space
ideally White doesn't want to trade in
this position too much let's play Knight
c3 I'm moving a little bit slowly but I
like my position I wanna play Bishop III
but the b-pawn would be hanging maybe
nine eight four and the affor looks
interesting question the Queen may be
going for a c5 in Knight b6 yeah let's
play c5 making the structure a bit more
dynamic c5 looks like a positional
mistake because it makes us pawn
backward it gives him the d5 square but
I think I'm okay with this maybe Bishop
takes e5 Knight b6 like the queen is a
bit awkward my trap is Queen Bishop d2
queen b5 over the Queen's very close to
getting trapped um I don't know if I can
actually trap it I'm reeling well in
time I could trap his rook Bishop f4 I
was so focused on trapping the Queen
that is rook just is lost here or is it
take oh my gosh tactics okay that's kind
of annoying but I have this move
this is a weird sequence of moves I'm
not sure what's going on
wanna play 97 but Bishop take d7 I could
play queen h5 almost trucks with Bishop
he has to play Bishop e6 taked I also
have Bishop d2 to throw in its a weird
position I'm running way too long time
okay let's start with this he's gonna
play Bishop e6 and I play rookie two
I'll slowly build up
oh he's gonna pressure d4 I have Bishop
e5 if necessary ooh he's allowing Bishop
d6 gets to go back to e7 or this happens
and I'm up to exchange okay he has a
pawn for the exchange it's still gonna
take work to win this he's attacking two
pawns let's defend maybe I missed
something earlier I don't know um but
now I just gotta play quickly there's a
g4 interesting my queen is tied down to
defending the rook the good news is I
have the open e file and is usually good
if you control an open file when you're
up exchange you can use that file to
make good things happen let's play a3
first maybe b4 and then rookie more and
eventually I throw in f3 as well and
keep the file controlled maybe I'll
throw in g4 just kick the bishop around
I'm King G to put the Queen on e5 if you
bring maybe I'll triple up get the
Alekhine's guy I know
and ideas of Queenie 8lu Queenie it may
have been very strong the previous move
now it doesn't work okay I have to do
this oh we're trading uh let's what do I
do
okay I didn't want to take because it
gives him the e4 square that's really
annoying let's play g5 I'll bring the
King to f4 this is scary I just walk in
with my king like what else to do
defend the Jeep on he's gonna play rook
h5 oh I didn't want to do that oh man I
wonder if like he got four but I let go
of that too soon okay gotta play quick
move I defend that maybe I can made him
please let me meet you mmm okay things
are getting traded I have 10 seconds
left nine seconds left
no I lost upon no okay he didn't take it
why didn't he take it
he's playing too too quickly
okay now I'm completely winning my rook
is very nicely placed I should win this
easily
Oh Ella's bad technique okay three
seconds to meet I actually practice this
against for my students other day by
showing them how to uh win this I mean
oh no yay I win with 0.77 seconds left
that was not the best technique from
either of us but okay happy ending let's
go back to tournaments Oh
stressful okay deep breath I missed
everything in the chat for like the last
four minutes earlier people were just
saying hello hello to Nirvana Raymond
can you play the English opening next if
I might again I'll play the English
opening
g4x clam maybe I missed g4 at some
points I'm not at the park I'm actually
in my grandma's backyard and I'm playing
an English opening that's nice
okay II 6 we're gonna transpose into a
Queen's Gambit kind so one thing about
the English you have to be ready for
this
we'll do a qgd exchange variation with
g5 I normally play this from the black
side but I don't mind playing it from
the white side I think it's a relatively
easy setup for whites and sometimes in
blitz I like to be a bit more ambitious
and go for queenside castling and then
some sort of King side attack so see if
that can happen in this position maybe
I'll start with 92 leaving the option
open of f3 play Queen c2
and c5 is normal I could give him an IQ
P yeah I'm gonna treat this very
positionally because I like these IQ p
positions
I'm just blockading the d4 pawn and we
might end up trading a bunch of things
let me know if people can hear me okay I
have I'm like I'm set up on a very small
table and the microphone is a bit
further away than normal and it's
supposed to be close to get the best
audio that's hopefully it's uh it's not
that bad okay so my Queen's overworked
currently I have to defend the B to pawn
probably another time
I'm also not anywhere near an outlet so
the the charge on my computer is gonna
die pretty quickly just because a
computer overheats when I stream but it
should last another at least half hour I
would hope it's play rip d1 still
positional chess ooh I kind of forgot
about that move it's annoying because
it's the knight is pinned I would like
to be crazy here any craziness I can do
take take okay let's be civilized when I
get the chance I want to play Queen a
folder just get the Queen off the C file
hello to elastic hold haven't missed too
much so far okay I'm gonna take on f6
usually when you're playing against iqp
it's good to trade pieces I think that's
the general rule now I'll play Queen a4
I'm happy to trade more miners if Locke
is willing to znation chess I'm doing
well how are you
what's that and you just kept talking to
me okay
you won't hear her no okay sure
just have her call me she can call me
hmm so we'll still get Thai food soon
right what we're still going to get Thai
food okay okay sounds good yeah we'll
see her tomorrow yeah sounds good
so forty minutes okay okay it sounds
good
yeah my grandma says hi we're getting
Thai food in 40 minutes so yeah that was
that okay let me not flag this display
h3 yeah I'm in my grandma's backyard so
my grandma was having a conversation
with me thinking I was in the house but
not realizing I was outside so okay
let's let's play quickly here let's
destroy black's pawn structure and go
for queenie 5 maybe just attack
everything how long is a stream the
stream will last another 38 minutes
probably maybe 35 minutes because I have
to where we have to leave by 550
California time I have to move quicker
here what am i doing he's attacking a -
let's play a three it's defending
everything - it's kind of annoying but
rook d6 is coming why do I get in time
trouble like every game every games a
time scramble at least this game that's
slightly controlled and he's thinking
which is good now I'm attacking this guy
he's in the play rook c6 or that move
let's take pawns throw in the Czech
Queen c2 wins back the pawn actually it
doesn't mean back the pawn because the
queen is tied down to the rook please
take me to also b5 is hanging I can take
b5
now d5 is hanging this is a passed pawn
Oh tricky but it doesn't do anything
III doesn't work
attack the rook take the rook life is
good
okay two for two
delicious Thai food half an hour aren't
you tired of Thai food I actually had we
had Thai food yesterday but I never get
tired of Thai food I went to Thailand I
stream from Thailand a few months ago
and I had pad thai every day and did not
get tired it was so good and it was like
two dollars for a big portion yeah Thai
food is like the London system it's hard
to get tired of I have been overdosing
on the London though we're in California
and I I'm currently in Palm Springs I
was in San Francisco last week and in a
few days I'm going to LA so I'm taking a
whole California tour enjoying the warm
weather
Thai food has msg um does it I'm
actually not too aware I'm sure there is
some Thai food without msg maybe I
should be a more more aware of what I
eats okay I'm gonna play 95 it's a
pleasant position complete development
there's actually a trap here well maybe
there's not a trap I was gonna say if 97
is might take a 7 but there would also
be Knight takes c6 so 9h five
interesting move curious if I can take
on d5 probably doesn't work
I'm gonna do this well everyone wants to
call me hello hey how's it going oh sure
um yeah I'm free later so not too much
going on oh that's right yeah I can let
you in when you guys get back okay
sounds good see you bye I don't think
I've had a stream where like so many
people want to talk to me it's
distracting I have to multitask it's
play B for wait before might be
weakening before G to have to it and f6
is annoying Oh what to do Bishop f3
maybe Bishop f3 I'll get some some kind
of funny pawn structure after a bishop
they got three G take f3 my pawns are
just kind of a lump on the Kings side
it's huge
what's huge oh the backyard is huge yeah
maybe I can give it to her oh maybe I
can get quadruple pawns it's hard to do
though I really want quadruple pawns
doesn't happen too often
I take d5 as other move it's an idea
it doesn't work though I can't take on
f6 wait f6 is actually really strong b4
could distract him
yeah before 96.5 me take some okay let's
do it
96 F 5.8 before and maybe like Queen B 3
this guy is only 1800 I'm probably
overthinking everything also forgot I
could have some tempo move against h7
like maybe Queen c2 in the near future
or Queen d3 at least our queen bee one
even choices choices
wait Knight 85 looks fun too and I take
T 5 Yolo
the idea is that I can play King f2 and
now Rick take h7 might be a threat it
might not be a threat but it will
hopefully make him think and you can't
put anything on f7 because e6 comes rook
take h7 King take your 7 rook h1 king g6
f5 king g5 f for king take g4 where's
the mates
there's gotta be mates not calculating
that's there's mate somewhere oh work h5
is mates oh that's nice
that's really nice wait is there a
prettier mate I still want quadruple
pawns okay rook a try that was nice yeah
I was calculating like f4 King here here
and then King take here and then the
King starts running away maybe there is
something I don't know
nice finish back to tournament second
place three for three
I'm not going to be able to finish this
treatment so I need to get a substantial
lead if I want to have a fight for first
place wait donation oh I have not been
checking stream lamps and singer $20
donation amazing as always
and the view is spectacular thank you so
much I'm singer 24 really appreciate it
and thank you to everyone else who's
followed Charlie woo with three o's
three o's three o's RPD 350 mellow war
thank you guys for following let's
bezerk this guy got some some adrenaline
rush from that last checkmate and from
the donation okay we'll play well play
hyper aggressively with the Budapest h3
useless move I wanted to take on e5
anyway now black has a nice lead in
development white has a very poor lead
in development maybe I can play Queen f6
going for cheapos yeah I was thinking
that this is still bad for whites
because his rook gets trapped maybe 92
yeah so I'm not winning the rook but I
like the position what to do rock a6
rook lifts it's been a while since I've
lifted and when I do lift I only lift
rooks bishop take a3 might be a free
pawn I mean I don't like to like
cherry-pick pawns but the threat is now
Bishop b4 and that would be just game
over if he lets me and he lets me idea
being 92 I can take on d2 and then the
rook is hanging that's nice I could
trade yeah let's just ring I'll win the
c5 pawn okay that was nice the berserk
and the hyper aggressiveness and the
budapest they all paid off okay
first place 13 points actually tied for
first place with par 40 35 minutes left
a Brandel tobots another 1800 something
I'm not gonna berserk this game let's
play d5 oh I want to play something new
but I'm gonna stick with what I know
this is kind of qgd setup he'll probably
play Kings Indian attack with d3 and
then I'll do my typical b6 and Bishop d7
bird flying overhead wait did this guy
disconnect oh now he's back okay
c3 it's a slower way of playing it's
still playable usually means that blacks
should play a bit more aggressively with
c5 I'm going to annoy him with Bishop a6
he wanted to play e4 but now now d3 is a
targets interesting let's play rook c8
positions like this both sides kind of
do their own thing but he seems to be
playing somewhat passively I'm gonna
continue to improve slightly Jorian
raised in California we're in California
if there's any viewers who are in LA and
you would like to meet up in a few days
let me know I don't know if I'll have
any time but I am curious who the the
California viewers are PlayBook c7 this
Bishop wants to go back
it's very closed position black has
slightly more space positions like this
they can meet two very long games I'm
going for this f5 break I probably have
to prepare it a few more moves now is a
good time for f5 potential ideas are at
four Bishop g5 it's kind of annoying its
Queen d7 I still want to play off for
you might take takings probably a good
move but he doesn't take time for f4 I
took five minutes on my name one bit
thank you so much very grateful now I
want to trap the bishop maybe Queen g7
threatening h6 I don't know how he's
gonna save this Bishop got too deep into
my territory and singer says I'm going
to sign up to play my first rather my
first rather tournament in July I think
he means rated tournament that's cool
yeah there's so many people who play
chess online that have never actually
played a rated event and I mean maybe a
decade ago that was very rare but
nowadays it's very common over the board
tournaments can be a lot different than
simply playing online this guy
disconnects to be ragequit after after
the bishop trap
I mean he does have he could play g4
it's not it's not trivial but I have
Noi's g3 that's a nice word for the
Knights
I want to keep the table there it would
be really bad if my laptop fell off the
table because like the pool is right
here okay but yeah I'm still winning the
bishop cuz if he takes on g3 I take back
with check so he's gonna try and get
condensation but now digit be seven
keeping the pressure there was a very
unfortunate incident though the first
and only World Youth Championship I
played that was in Brazil and it was at
some like nice resorts with some some
pools and during one of the rounds I had
my backpack with me with my laptop and I
gave it to my dad and the backpack
wasn't zipped fully and my dad was like
walking back to the hotel and somehow
the laptop fell out of the backpack
as he was like walking by the pool now
the laptop didn't fall in the pool but
the laptop battery popped out of the
laptop and that fell in the pool and it
was very very bad because all my prep
was on the laptop now luckily the laptop
battery uh it was okay it was dead but I
was able to to still plug in the laptop
and that worked okay but it was a scare
so laptops and pools don't really mix I
didn't really mean to give up my queen
like that but I mean I have two rooks in
the night and this bishop is so bad
let's play not here I guess I do have to
pay attention to what he wants to do on
the Queen side but I don't think his
Queen can enter
let me put my bishop on a floor this is
just like positional heaven for black
he has no active plans like his queen is
useless and his bishop is useless let's
invade I kind of forgot about time but I
have the time advantage ah let's invade
further Roque 193 everything's defended
accepted bishop but that's okay what to
do
maybe this and then after King g2 I'll
play rook here hmm what to do I mean I
could just fog him I want to win in some
like nice fashion and then improve my
king
maybe rook c3 and then knight Knight c5
I'll go after the D pawn bishop c2 if
necessary that's nice everything's still
defended take all the pawns
okay that was a nice game okay clear
first place I'm gonna be right back and
get a grapefruits
there's a grapefruit tree right there I
don't know if people can see that but
here's a grapefruits put the camera back
oh let's play you six
I'm not sure if I'm gonna eat this
grapefruit but I just wanted something
to play with uh what is this is this the
Queen's Gambit yeah this is just Queens
gambit declined exchange variation Wow
thanks for the five bits the ultimate
donation appreciate that Bishop f5 if
they allow Bishop at five you should
play Bishop at five and then castle oh
he's playing really quickly and I'm
playing really slowly
I should stop playing with the
grapefruits I think a six slowing down
the minority attack and then I'm gonna
do this normal like Knight maneuver yeah
we have a very typical like Carlsbad
structure there's a few plans for a
black one plans to get some attack on
the Kings side other plans just apply 94
looks reasonable it's always easy to
attack here because white doesn't have
too many weaknesses but maybe I can
start with this move ideas of this in
this
should be too natural now night g6 could
run into g4 let's just centralize a rook
ideas of rook t6 I just want to throw
all my pieces
towards the king side Connor jf I'm so
jealous of that sunshine yeah I guess
there's many places on the planet
currently where it's kind of dark but
the Sun is still out I guess I have to
trade bishops I'll play Knight g6
we could trade off all the Knights yeah
now there's ideas of G v g6 King g7
Andrew H eights with some h-file action
I mean he might go for some Queen trade
but I probably don't want to trade
Queens here because there's so much
potential for a King side attack yeah
let's keep Queens on the board it's
gonna be a fight
oh he's going for the minority attack
what to do g6
yeah the minority attack is actually
really annoying I'm just gonna focus on
the King side play what to do
take take I could get the past a pawn
that's a common response to the Queen
side thrust is to play a five and then
maybe eventually be 6 but B 6 we can see
6 let's play rook I can't play rook aids
now I have to play what do I play here
mm this is not good it's not easy to
find a move I could sac up on maybe I
have to sack up on
wait he's not threatening to take if
he's not threatening to take okay let's
do this
maybe he is threatening to take I don't
know Rach take a 5 B 6 Rick C 6
take-take-take and it's playable that's
probably okay because in the eight pawns
past I just want to play g4 I don't know
if g4 it doesn't anything maybe rook h4
and then g4 it's risky my time situation
is very suspicious I think I'm losing a
pollen here but losing a pawn isn't the
end of the world because this B pawn
will be weak I'm now I'm threatening
this and then winning the rook and his
rook is tied down to the beef on maybe
he'll play b6 or that now I win b5 okay
so it's equal material it's not equal
time but okay I'll play quickly in this
position defend the rook I have a passed
pawn oh I forgot about that pawn I can
defend it though let's play rook here
stopping Queen e5 this is uncomfortable
I can eat seven maybe he's still gonna
play h5 I have to defend Queen g6 maybe
at some point wait I want to draw he's
playing smart he knows I don't want to
draw I should probably take a draw he's
over 2,000 what do I do this move
to put the rook on somewhere more useful
wait this is really bad rook b8 oh I
don't want a cream of that get ready to
play b5 this is interesting actually I'm
down so many pawns but my B pawn is
running oh I don't get my king quick
enough in time okay so we have to go for
the slam
ouch his three pawns bugs are flying on
me
hey I flagged him with 0.14 seconds left
I didn't think I was gonna win that good
thing I didn't take that draw I'm still
in first place luck is in my favor I
still have the grapefruit good luck
grapefruits okay playing another
eighteen eighty Coco 83 its berserk Oh
too late I was gonna try to desert
trying to extend the lead I'm only
leading the tournament by one points we
have a London system
very topical and theoretical line there
should be seven asana commonly see for
allows he for this is already nice for
whites I'm singer wants to meet to play
a Vienna yeah I should play e4 if I get
the chance
next game if I'm white I'll play E for
and try for Vienna let's play H for
maybe he'll Castle and walk into a great
gift
hey it's happening h4 o is kind of just
a hopeful move I'm pretty sure this is
winning King g6 I have uh H 5 H 5 should
be crushing cuz ok King f6 live Knight
h7 this is nice as Kings going for a
walk I could calculate or I could just
move king at five where is it mate uh g4
wait g4 can take f4 Queen g2 I mean
there's some quiet move like Queen f3
should do the job I would like to have
for Smith though as Queen c2 can take
out for g3 hmm I don't really want to
sack that Bishop but maybe it's good
enough
oh yeah g3 King G for those Queenie for
native king up 3 there's Queen e2 King G
- ooh can i castle with Nate's way
Queenie for mates with the King on g2 ok
pretty sure this is force mates I guess
he has king g4 here but I'm expecting
him to take the bishop now I'm
controlling all these squares so this
King has to move up if King G for Queen
e4 is mate right and if King here
there's this this and then mates
okay well that was nice
it's the power of the Greek gift back to
tournaments it's not the smoothest way
to win all the games but that was a
pretty nice game I was uh yeah that was
a nice attacking win it was forcemeat
weights fancy kiddo
g4 and then Queen f3 I'm sure they're
there probably was multiple force mates
in that position
I'm worried again I'll try and get a
Vienna never mind we'll play a nice III
Sicilian notifications okay this should
be five let's see how much he knows I
stopped playing this line specifically
because it's not that hard to play for a
black if Mike knows what he's doing but
then again it's still not bad for blitz
White has a simple summit aren't you
going to eat the grapefruit I would eat
the grapefruit but I'm going to for your
Thai food very soon probably save the
grapefruit for later I also like to
refrigerate the grapefruit before I eat
it I like my grapefruits cold I don't
know if that's a weird thing but I don't
know it's just more refreshing that way
h5 he wants to kill me I think I could
just ignore him let's start with this
move
I do have to watch out for ideas of like
this and this and bishops are scary H
for let's play h3 preventing black from
playing h3 evh that doesn't work
the Queen's I defended on f3 after G for
over her into the other game so 9 h5
annoying move because I can't I mean I
want to play this
this f4 push but g3 gets weak maybe they
just play on this side there's potential
to play on both both wings of the board
and a5 you'll see this too often but
this beep on is now artificially
isolated it's artificially isolated
because technically there's a pawn on
adjacent file but the a pawn is stuck on
a6 now I can play rock a4 maybe or Queen
e1 let's play Queen e1 whoa he's being
super aggressive but now Rock a 4 and I
think I'm winning upon more bits from I
took 5 mins on my name thanks so much
some salts for that timeout earlier what
time outs did someone get timeout
timeout it timed out I have a vague
memory of hero giving someone a timeout
but I forget who it was okay I want to
take the pawn and want to take the pawn
he's just bluffing on the Kings side
I mean maybe he'll play G for it but
doesn't look too scary
I thought euro gave us someone a timeout
it's maybe I'm just like hallucinating
or I was dreaming I mean here is a good
nod so if you give someone a timeouts I
think it's for the right reasons okay
he's playing g4 I mean can I just take
it
o'night g 3i g 3 oh there's some scary
meeting ideas but I could play King G 1
yeah I think if I took a good night with
a pawn there would be force mate
I completely forgot my rook was not was
on f1 that was in oops I can play out
for maybe I for Queen g7 he hits a pawn
I could take on f8 first wait Queen H
shoes coming what that's okay though
[Music]
okay I didn't mean to lose a rook I
should have just saw that line coming oh
oh h3 wait this is really bad I better
not lose this this would be a dumb way
to lose a game my King has to run I'm
low on time that okay things are a bit
messy he still has to take my bishop I'm
expecting H take g2 and then King you
too and I'll just plant my queen on g1
or maybe in this case planted on each
one though maybe I could trap this Queen
how do i attack his Queen Queen d4 let's
play Queen before it keeps the physician
spicy I mean I could have just traded
Queens but no I like the spiciness I'm
preparing for the Thai food
Queen g5 I don't know if that's a threat
but it looks fun and the rook will come
to h1 maybe Queen f6 first d4 is hanging
and White has everything under control I
could just take d4 and then do this it
wasn't necessary to allow all of this
but og fours attacked I mean I could
just flag him okay that was nice
back to tournament I paused it because
I'm not sure if I'm gonna play another
game what's my percentage at 26% okay
I'll play one more game my grandma might
come and start like telling me to pack
things up one more game I'll probably
have to preserve whoever I play
oh I'm singer if you want your vienna
it's a top game here
kind of a weird vienna okay um let me
check stream labs yeah thanks for the
bits just mock thanks for following oh
oh yes okay can you give me five minutes
okay
okay this games not going to take more
than five minutes let's play Grand Prix
I'm gonna try and crush them quickly try
and go out with a bang
interesting it's playoff five sometimes
you have to be unsound to be aggressive
I don't mind this so maybe I do mind it
can take there's pressure though like a
sevens week
Bishop f6 maybe that's a good move
we'll see if he's brave enough to play
g5 oh I forgot about that move I'm not
losing anything though like my bishops
hanging but his knights hang and if his
light moves I have Queen take g6 please
move your Knights okay so I'm still down
upon but I'm just down upon and he's
consolidating that's unfortunate and I'm
down that time okay Queen i6 I'm gonna
fight here I'll play rogue up three I'm
gonna still try and attack rook up three
rook can't play rock h3 then maybe I'll
triple up and it's hard to remove the
Queen on f6 what a free pawn thank you I
have to trade Queens p3 maybe you wanted
to play B 4 and then Bishop you - things
are getting traded wait that's not good
for whites this is not good
take take okay I'm gonna play
defensively I'm going to try and hold
onto the pawn you might play f5 and then
I play e5 he's gonna play f4 no ok c3 I
can take any time I want like right now
ooh maybe I shouldn't have taken that
okay I have to play quick what's
material materials equal I have double
pawns
I have 17 seconds I'm gonna run the King
to a four maybe mm-hmm it's kind of
annoying but now his rook is stuck maybe
I can trap this rook somehow or just go
after that five fine I have to move much
quicker
please take start pre moving
so stressful
[Music]
no he's promoting first no oh no this is
bad this is really bad and I had five
seconds left
it's just run out of checks please run
out of checks please please no yes Rick
take g3 with check wait does he have any
more checks I don't think has any more
checks he ran out but I have three
seconds left
oh this is scary oh no this is really
bad that's made in one no oh he didn't
see it no I flagged oh okay I'm ending
the stream there that was a really
disappointing finish I still have my
grapefruit and it's time for Thai food I
will see you guys maybe later but for
now I am leaving oh I didn't mean to
share my desktop but bye guys